mon chéri tu as vu ce qui arrive aux
chroniqueurs total de la crème ouais ils
ont dû chocolat et on avait piégé
notre grand patron le président de sifca
piéto et j'ai un cadeau à lui faire ce
soir parce que franck a plutôt regardé
on la dpg il ya quelques semaines avec
la bande à fifi
regardez regardez vous on va retourner
là bas l'année prochaine
gérald brice viret patron du groupe
canal
voilà c'est le directeur des pointes de
tout le groupe canal+ et francs capitaux
le président de ses 8 merci les chéris
merci merci de bien que non mais voilà
tout ça voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à la bombe
je rassure
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà mes chéris et regardez c'est
l'élégance c'est l'élégance à la
princesse francs capitaux il est
toujours prisés les grandes président et
j'ai décidé voilà de bien surprendre les
frais de pressing à ma charge et il
était revenue aujourd'hui dans le studio
pour que je lui redonne son costume il
est là il en loge il est bien voilà mon
chéri merci mon bébé d'un an à mon frère
c'est adorable
merci rires et parce que c'est alors
qu'il voulait pas il est tout propre il
est tout propre et toi mon chéri franck
appelé tout je voulais dire franck toi
tu as eu 2 et était bien été bien lotis
il ya du président en ce moment les
émissions sont tellement drôle
c'est vrai ah oui non mais j'adore ça
c'est content des émissions mais je suis
très content des émissions alors je
voudrais dire quelque chose parce que
franck mon chéri tu as vu ce qui arrive
aux chroniqueurs total de la crème
ouais et ils ont des chocolats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
john du prez prendre mon blog je venais
au tournant
[Applaudissements]
g
les oies terme sur des amateurs notre
famille renard est tombé samus investir
assez c'est assez
bravo et bravo à mathieu tu lui a sauvé
la tête allait alors patron est ce qu'on
va on va revoir les images n'ont rien
fait de mal je me plais calimero métier
boivin dre cheryl vous inquiétez pas
jean-michel monchy russie vous allez
rire si on va revoir les images de
francs capitaux sans le grand président
de ses huit à neuf au dessus de la
personne non au dessus de nous mais à
part ça c'est un choix est à vous bah
oui franc que c'est mon patron c'est à
dire que tous les matins il ma gueule
ouais voilà c'est vrai si numéro 7 du
fidèle et mongols comme pascal modique
je vous mets trop de chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
installez busch deviendra vous prenez
vous installez vous indique jeudi un et
y aller je le dis pas je vais revenir
obtiendra pas 4h30 comme ça réponde à
leur stress ce plan est que même le
teich 2 5g cardinal hongrois patron
j'habitais du respect l' horrible c'est
du respect je ne sens pas là ce soir on
se tasse mais elle va revoir la
fréquence avec avec un arrêté vont
regarder c'est l'élégance c'est
l'élégance à la française frank apitoyer
toujours très élégant notre président et
j'ai décidé voilà de bien surprendre les
frais de pressing à ma charge et il
était revenue aujourd'hui dans le studio
pour que je le mets redonne son costume
il est là il en loge il est bien voilà
mon chéri merci beaucoup plus d'un avant
frère c'est adorable
merci rires et parce que c'est alors ils
voulaient pas on est tous propres
il est tout propre et toi mon chéri
franck après tout je vais dire franck
toi tu as eu de cet été était bien tu es
bien lotis oui il ya du président en ce
moment les émissions sont tellement
drôle
c'est vrai ah oui non mais j'adore ça
c'est content des émissions mais je suis
très content des émissions alors je
voudrais dire quelque chose parce que
franck mon chéri tu as vu ce qui arrive
aux chroniqueurs total de la crème ouais
ils ont des chocolats
[Applaudissements]
je reprends le costume est bien sûr et
bien entendu mon chéri j'enlèverai de
ton costume et et je vous le dise ah
ouais ce costume je vous le dis je vais
l'amener au pressing et le pressing
enlèvera tout le chocolat alors qu'il
avait 17 ans
et franck tu es le meilleur patron tête
mon choix
[Musique]